la situation de l'Ukraine était au cœur
hier du sommet à Bruxelles de l'Union
européenne un paquet de sanctions un
neuvième paquet de sanctions a été
adopté contre la Russie mais avant cela
l'Union européenne a convenu d'apporter
une aide supplémentaire à l'Ukraine
d'une valeur de 18 milliards d'euros je
vous propose d'écouter ce qu'on a dit la
présidente de la Commission européenne
pour sous la forme de rayonne
nous continuerons à soutenir le crâne
aussi longtemps qu'il le faudra
l'Union européenne a comme vous le savez
soutenu financièrement l'Ukraine cette
année à hauteur de 19,7 milliards
d'euros et grâce à la présidence tchèque
notre proposition de 18 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires pour 2023 a été
adopté aujourd'hui
il s'agissant de ce neuvième paquet de
sanctions adoptées contre la Russie de
quoi parle-t-on exactement pierre
Benazet à Bruxelles
alors essentiellement d'abord de
nouvelles inscriptions
personnel sur la liste des personnes qui
sont privées d'entrer dans l'Union
européenne ou qui voient leurs avoir
gelés dans lieu elles étaient déjà 1240
et une sur cette liste il y en aura 200
de plus la liste n'est pas encore
complètement officielle parce qu'il faut
qu'elle soit publiée au Journal officiel
de l'Union européenne pour l'être par
ailleurs il y aura surtout encore des
restrictions économiques sectorielles
par exemple la défense de tout
investissement dans le secteur minier
russe c'est ça le plus important point
de ce paquet petit à petit l'Union
européenne construit un écheveau de
sanction qui viennent frapper la plupart
des secteurs de l'économie russe visant
à la comprimer la plus efficacement
possible les Européens estiment que leur
sanctions sont efficaces elles rajoutent
à chaque fois ces sanctions un petit
cran supplémentaire dans les secteurs
qui ont été oubliés ou les secteurs qui
pourraient permettre de contourner
d'autres sanctions il fallait aussi
s'attaquer au secteur des industries
pour les importations à double usage
civils et militaires ces choses faites
maintenant les chefs d'État du
gouvernement de l'Union européenne n'ont
pas encore résolu problème du
plafonnement du prix du gaz ils n'ont
pas encore trouvé de solutions à long
terme pour contrer non plus la loi
américaine sur la réduction de
l'inflation bref il reste du travail en
Europe